zach is in Green Bay Wisconsin hi Zach
how are you yeah how are you did better
than I deserve what's up yeah so I just
had a quick question
um I am currently doing the public
forgiveness loan awesome I you didn't
loan and I missed about six years see so
I'll they have about four years left my
balance is about 26,000 currently I
don't pay anything a month due to my
household size and income but I'm
considering a career move into the
private private sector which I wouldn't
be qualified for the public forgiveness
loan anymore so I'm just wondering if I
should I start paying towards my student
loans just in case I do decide to take a
different job in the future
what is your income now 32,000
for myself and then my wife is at about
16,000 okay about forty five forty six
thousand how many kids do you have
we have two it's for my wife's previous
marriage we pay so we have 50/50 custody
in touch okay and if you made a career
move what would you make right now I did
like an informal interview and we I
still have to sit down with the
gentleman obviously I would have to take
into consideration you know having to
pay my student loans back on currently I
asked I asked how much you would make it
the new job probably about forty
thousand so eight thousand dollars a
year more yeah okay so in three years on
the student loans of 26,000 you break
even yep everything after that's gravy
okay yeah there's no question you do
that there's no question you do but I
mean I would take the job before I
before I change my game plan but as soon
as you change your game plan then I
would get after it definitely you know
that's um you know you want to clear the
student loan I
Your Honor I would love to see your
household income come up dramatically
40,000 just being the first jump and
then you continue to work from there and
and move along right now you're at about
average and I'd like for you to see you
know have some goals to get you well
above average and you know create this
whole income situation where 26,000 is
not your motivator anymore boom you just
knock it out fast and be done with it
that that's what I'd rather see you do
good question thank you for joining us